>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Georgette Dorn: Good afternoon.
My name is Georgette
Dorn and I'm the Head
of the Hispanic Division
Library of Congress and I can say
that this library is
the home of Borges.
He always said when he came to
visit us many times in the 60s,
70s and 80s, "Esta es mi
casa" This is my home.
So, it's a great pleasure to
welcome here his wonderful widow
and collaborator, Maria Kodama.
So, this very exciting event will be
helded by the Embassy of Argentina,
by Ambassador Martin Lousteau.
He is Argentina's Ambassador and
Minister of [inaudible] he comes
by a time that he would
be doing a great job
in the [inaudible] the relations
between Argentina and
the United States.
He's a graduate of
universities in Buenos Aires,
and also the London School of
Economics and Politics Science.
He's the author of many books
and has been a columnist
for major Argentine newspapers.
He served in the government of
President Cristina Kirchner,
the Ambassador's also a member
of the Argentine Congress
and he was a he was a world fellow
[phonetic] at the EN University.
Maria Kodama is the
collaborator wife
and soul of Borges in many ways.
She was the writer's collaborator of
many years and she's the [inaudible]
of the state of Borges, one would
say the guardian of the state.
She was a professor of literature
at the University of Buenos Aires
and the translator of Borges,
"El libro de la almohada".
Saul Sosnowski, is professor of
literature and the University
of Maryland in College Park.
He's a graduate of
University of Virginia
and have founded the
Issues [phonetic]
of International Studies
the University of Maryland,
he was the Vice [phonetic] for many
years at the University of Maryland.
He has travelled [inaudible]
with Borges sometimes
and he has written a book of
Borges, "Borges y la Kabala",
and he translated, "El
libro de la almohada".
So, with us the three speakers.
Thank you -- and the ambassador.
[ Applauses ]
>> Martin Lousteau:
Thank you Georgette
and good evening everyone
and welcome.
Usually when ambassadors
are asked to speak
about a great fellow countryman,
we are given written pieces
that tell their deeds, their
personal characteristics
and sometimes our own
experiences regarding this people.
I've done that in -- regarding
Borges in a recent seminar
that George W University organized.
And I'm very glad that I'm not going
to embarrass myself
by doing that tonight.
The reason being that
today among us we have --
for this commemoration and homage
to one of the greatest writers
in world literature, we have the
person who knew Borges the most
and who knows his work the most.
We are really honored and
I'm really pleased to be able
to introduce a writer,
translator, literature professor,
the creator of the Jorge
Luis Borges foundation
and besides all that,
the writer's widow.
So, Maria Kodama, welcome, thank
you very much for being here.
Maria has dedicated her whole
life to spread Borges' legacy
around the world so I think that
the best thing that I can do is
to begin this presentation
by quoting Maria herself.
When asked last month why Borges'
work was becoming increasingly
relevant, she replied, "Because
his work not only tells a story,
but also underlies within
philosophy, religion
and scientific curiosities and the
proof of this is that after he left,
the fields of mathematics,
philosophy,
neurosciences also became
interested in his work.
This also happened to Jules Verne.
In each century a person is
born, neither better nor worse
but who possesses the potential
to see what we don't see.
And that person plants the
seed of fantastic literature
which is a reality today
as is space travel.
Borges certainly saw what
other people could not
and he generously shared his
magical worlds letting us navigate
new dimensions."
This is true to such an extent
that critics were forced
to create a new word, a new logism,
"Borgesium", to capture the --
I wouldn't say words, but
the magical state of mind
that Borges invented and gave us.
Maria with her tireless work not
only helps make this magic world
remain alive but also for this world
to gain an ever increasing
number of followers.
Recently Maria published,
"Homenaje a Borges" The book
that I think Saul has in his hand,
where she compiled 20 lectures
she has given at universities
and institutions worldwide
during the last 30 years.
This is a clear example of Maria's
work, also as Georgette said,
we are really honored to be
celebrating this here today.
Not only because Borges
claimed this to be his home,
but also because it is a library,
and libraries are important,
not only in Borges' life
but also in his work.
And his stayed here at the US.
The Library of Congress has
collaborated with the embassy
to present you this amazing array
of first edition books by Borges',
a documentary and some audios of
the Argentine writer that are part
of the library's collection.
Now, as I said before, I'm so glad
I'm not going to speak anymore
and to speak about Jorge Luis Borges
I give the floor to the person
who knew him the best and
who might really thank
for coming here as
our especial guest.
Maria, thank you very much
for being here, it is an honor
and Saul, the floor is all yours.
Thank you very much and enjoy.
[ Applauses ]
>> Saul Sosnowki: Thank you Mr.
Ambassador, thank you Georgette.
This is home for many of
us so it's good to be back.
Before we start let me introduce
Melissa Gonzales Contreras
who is a PhD student at
the University of Maryland
and she will be summarizing
the comments
that Maria Kodama will
make, in response to some
of the questions that I've prepared.
Empiezo, ¿qué era
para nosotros el arte?
El texto que cierra tu homenaje a
Borges quizá me sirva para trazar un
itinerario, teniéndolo
siempre presente,
¿cuál es la primera imagen que
se te aparece al decir, "Borges"?
I'll translate.
In this book that the
ambassador mentioned,
"Homenaje a Borges"
Maria Kodama has a text
that is called, "What
was art for us?"
And that's the final
text that closes the book
that I think might
serves us as an itinerary
for tonight's conversation.
So, having Borges always in
mind, present, the question is,
"What is the first image that
comes to mind to Maria Kodama just
by simply saying Borges?"
>> Maria Kodama: I don't know.
>> Saul Sosnowski:
Será que lo prendemos.
Permiso.
>> Maria Kodama: Excuse I
understand English [inaudible]
but I don't speak it properly,
the next one I'm going
to answer in Spanish.
And you can ask me in English OK?
[Inaudible] realmente es como decían
en España [inaudible] es decir,
la primera aproximación que yo tuve
a Borges sin saber que era Borges,
fue una lectura que le hizo una
profesora que debía enseñarle inglés
y evidentemente no le enseñó pero
yo me divertía muchísimo con ella
porque me hacía un resumen de lo que
ella estaba leyendo que eran textos
para adultos por supuesto.
Y decía en español [inaudible] y
seguía ella con su lectura y lo más
interesante que una vez me leyó
[inaudible] Borges [Inaudible] era
una mujer de la que él había
estado enamorado [inaudible].
Y para una creatura de
cinco años, [inaudible];
me llenó porque decía él que ella
-- él le ofrecía a ella su fracaso,
su soledad [inaudible]
el hambre de mi corazón.
Para una creatura de cinco años
el hambre del corazón era lo que
es [inaudible].
Yo tenía cinco años y
bueno, era realista.
Entonces ella le contestó que
el hambre del corazón era amor y
que [inaudible].
Y esa esa fue la primera vez, la
segunda vez cuando [inaudible],
yo tendría 10 años y cayó
en mis manos una revista.
Esa revista seguramente
era [inaudible].
Entonces yo empecé a leer,
"Nadie los vio desembarcar
en la unánime noche",
y yo dije, ¿qué es esto?
Lo he leído hasta el final
sin entender una palabra,
pero hasta el día de hoy si
tuviéramos que quemar la obra de
todos los escritores
salvando solo una,
esa es la única que yo salvaría.
Y es muy interesante porque muchos
[inaudible] de los años [inaudible]
que publicaron y me dieron
para que yo hiciera el prólogo,
un libro de entrevistas que
[inaudible] Campo había hecho a
Borges [inaudible] fotografías.
Entonces llegó el momento en el que
yo [inaudible] atentamente tenía que
hacer el prólogo y en un
momento ella le dice, "Borges,
acá hay una casa que tiene un jardín
a la izquierda y una escalera a la
derecha", y Borges
contestó, "Si es esa,
es la casa de la calle [inaudible]
donde yo en una semana escribí
"Las ruinas circulares".
Durante esa semana yo trabajaba con
[inaudible] pero lo único que quería
era [inaudible] esa casa para
escribir ese cuento porque nunca,
ni antes ni después pude escribir un
cuento con la intensidad con que yo
escribí ese cuento.
Es decir que esa intensidad
[inaudible] chica de 10 años que no
entendió nada, pero que hasta el día
de hoy quedó atrapada con ese cuento
y que sería el único que
yo salvaría [inaudible].
Y es un fascinante, es fascinante
y lamenté tanto que Borges ya no
estuviera porque a él le hubiera
encantado porque yo le decía,
¿Qué le gusto de ese cuento?,
No sé, una intensidad una cosa,
pero él nunca me dijo eso.
Pero se lo dijo en esa entrevista
Victorio Campo cuando Victorio Campo
le describía la foto.
[inaudible] es fascinante.
>> Saul Sosnowski: ¿Y esa es
la primera imagen que te viene a
la mente?
¿Es ese cuento?
>> Maria Kodama: Es ese cuento, sí.
Es ese cuento.
>> Saul Sosnowski: Yes, good luck.
[ Laughter ]
This is just going
to be a summary, OK?
>> Melissa: OK, the first memory
is not really an image but it's a,
"de oídas", yes, [inaudible].
The first time was a teacher
who taught her to speak English,
the teacher would read the
- whatever she was reading
at that time to her and one day
she read two poems by Borges and --
that was dedicated
to a man and a woman.
She was five years old by the time.
>> Saul Sosnowski: Not
the woman but the --
>> Melissa: No, no.
In the poems Borges offered
his solitude to this woman
and his hunger of heart,
"hambre de corazón".
So, Mrs. Kodama being a 5
year-old girl felt intrigued
by this description and asked what
it meant, her teacher responded,
"That's love, one day
you'll understand".
The second time was when she was
10 years old reading, revista Azul,
she read a text by Borges
and according to her,
she didn't understand it either and
in an interview with Victorio Campo,
Borges mentioned a where he
wrote, "Las Ruinas Circulares",
and he mentioned that he just
wanted to return to that house
because that house
allowed him to write
with intensity that short story.
And this is what captured Mrs.
Kodama from Borges, his intensity.
>> Good job.
>> Saul Sosnowski: Thank you.
Indeed. So, well, all right.
The several stories in which Borges
since you said that -- can I --
¿Te lo pregunto en
Inglés o en castellano?
¿De una vez?
¿Sí?
>> Maria Kodama: Si
no entiendo te digo.
>> Saul Sosnowski: Bueno.
In a number of stories, there is a
certain motive that comes up that --
and he also does it
in Tadeo Isidor Cruz,
La biografía de Tadeo Isidor
Cruz; that there is a moment
in a man's life I imagine
in woman's life too
that one will forever
know who he or she is.
So, the question is, what do you
think was that moment for Borges?
>> Maria Kodama: Well, I cannot say
what was that moment for Borges,
but I can say what was that the
moment for Borges life for mine.
>> Saul Sosnowski: Good,
that was the second question.
>> Maria Kodama: [Inaudible]
and then once we had to go
to Santiago de Chile to receive the
Doctorado Honoris Causa [inaudible].
Then [inaudible] and I said Borges
[inaudible] and he said, "Oh,
no nos hagamos ilusiones",
and he [inaudible] to speak
to the person [inaudible] when
he was talking to someone,
then I suddenly he gave me
[inaudible] he was in silence
and then he said, "thank
you, I appreciate [inaudible]
but there are two things that
[inaudible] cannot stand,
sobornar o dejarse sobornar.
>> Saul Sosnowski: To bribe or
to allow yourself to be bribed.
>> Maria Kodama: Then after
[inaudible] my duty is,
and I'm going to go to Chile, and
then I said to Borges [inaudible]
and he said, "¿Usted diría eso?
[Inaudible] no."
Then he took me in his arms
and said OK, is better this way
because I became the icon of
the Nobel prize [inaudible]
who could never [inaudible].
In this way, no.
So, so beautifully,
because you know,
nothing can change his
principles, nothing can change that.
And I admire that.
[Inaudible].
>> Saul Sosnowski: Thank you.
You got an excellent
English teacher by the way.
>> Maria Kodama: No, no.
Did you understand?
Yes? [Crosstalk].
>> Saul Sosnowski: I
remember one time he also said
that he's been a candidate
for so long
that people probably forgot
the he already got it.
That's why he's no
longer a candidate.
And --
In this same book, there is a text
that is called, "¿Qué
es el tiempo?"
And you begin with a quote
from Saint Agustin that says,
"¿Qué es pues el tiempo?
Si nadie me lo pide, lo sé.
Si quiero explicárselo a
quién me lo pide, no lo sé.
What is time?
If nobody will ask me what
it is, I know what it is.
But if somebody is going
to ask me to explain it,
I do not know what time is."
The question would then be,
"What was the time with Borges?
And what has it been
for you since 1986?
>> Maria Kodama: As with Borges?
From 1986 and continue, because --
[ Inaudible ]
And for me on working with
[inaudible] and more physically
with you, but there is [inaudible].
>> Saul Sosnowski: That's
what you always say.
>> Maria Kodama: Yeah, that's it.
>> Saul Sosnowski: In one of
those essays you also wrote,
"Creo que nadie puede ser mero
espectador de un proceso de
creación, sobre todo de alguien que
como Borges emanaba una fuerza tan
especial para la que uno
se sentía arrastrada."
And in one of these
essays Maria Kodama says
that nobody can be just a
spectator in the creative process,
particularly in Borges' case because
there was such a strong power
that was emanating
from it that one felt
that was being carried away by it.
My question is, "Is there some
sort of text that you remember
in particular that carried
you away more than others,
besides the Circle of Ruines.
>> Saul Sosnowski: Why?
>> Maria Kodama: Besides the
circle of Circle of Ruines.
Let me remember.
Maybe La Biblioteca [inaudible].
>> Maria Kodama: Maybe
the [inaudible] again.
Bueno la Biblioteca de Babel,
supongo que es por esa idea
[inaudible] de que todas las cosas
de alguna manera vuelven.
De en realidad nadie entiende
lo que está sucediendo.
[Inaudible], que es un
poco [inaudible] ¿no?
Así que sería así Biblioteca
de Babel, la circularidad,
la imposibilidad de la
comprensión y [inaudible].
Que no sabía [inaudible]
¿qué tiene?
[Inaudible] ¿Quién está?
Digamos ordenándose [inaudible]
entonces muy interesante [inaudible]
de la comprensión de [inaudible]
pensaba que sabe que iba a morir y
de pronto comprender
que no importa eso,
él está más allá de todo eso y es
como si él es mismo esa eternidad
[inaudible] y eso se lo
rebela la figura del tigre,
el tigre que está dando vueltas
alrededor de [inaudible].
Entonces esa referencia [inaudible]
comprender eso le fascina a él.
Nosotros tuvimos una experiencia
muy especial en el desierto.
[Inaudible].
[inaudible] nunca tuve
vacaciones, y según mis amigos,
esas eran vacaciones masoquitas.
Yo soy muy amiga de [inaudible] él
me ayudó a que yo fuera en una carpa
con los familiares de su secretario
y yo recuerdo que comía arena y
todo, no me importa, al
desierto con una carpa.
Y una [inaudible] yo recuerdo
y no puedo explicar cómo pero
intelectualmente sabe, uno,
no es nada, no es cierto?
[inaudible] emocionalmente
también, sabe que uno no es anda,
pero en ese momento, en ese lugar,
sentí el otro punto que yo
no sabía que existía en mí,
que "no soy nada".
Y eso para mí fue una revelación que
cambió la manera de ver muchísimas
cosas de mi propia
vida, [inaudible].
>> Saul Sosnowski: Estos botoncitos.
Ahí vamos.
>> Melissa: The two types
that she refered to is,
"La Biblioteca de Babel" And,
"El immortal" From la Biblioteca
de Babel, she likes the idea of --
that everything -- I'm sorry.
That no one understands what
happens, the circularity.
That they don't know who is
in charge of the library.
And from, "El Immortal" The idea
of comprehension at the present
that he knows that he will die
and that it doesn't matter.
And the idea of the eternity
and it's the figure of the tiger
that reveals this idea to him.
So, that the wisdom
in comprehending this,
and she has this fascination
with the desert.
In one trip to the desert
she realized she had
that same realization, that she
came to realize that she does --
she is no one, sorry,
I want to say that.
>> Saul Sosnowski: Esto lo
vamos a dejar prendido porque --
[inaudible] of course is
in, "Las Ruinas Circulares"
And therefore we can sort of
blend in with "El Inmortal".
But then he was dying.
Let me ask you something else.
He probably dictated
a lot of text to you.
The question is did he
tell you in advance,
"I'm going to dictate a poem, a
short story, I'm going to do this
or that", can you tell us a little
bit how he arrived from the moment
that he began to dictate to the
final version, knowing free will
that it was not the final version
because he always corrected.
The next one, the next
one and so on.
So, how did he start?
>> Maria Kodama: [inaudible]
he starts from [inaudible]
and then he think in the morning if
that is going to be useful or not,
if it's not going to be useful,
OK [inaudible] and if it is going
to be useful [inaudible] a poem
or a [inaudible] in his mind,
he begun to dictate or the poem
or the [inaudible] interesting
because in the foundation I have a
photo I think is the [inaudible] I'm
not sure [inaudible] Borges
is with the head like this,
and he's [inaudible] and that's
the way he begun to dictate.
It was like being blind,
is not sufficient for him
to go inside himself and go out
with a poem, with the [inaudible].
For me that's the image of
the beginning of the creation,
that's why I have a
photo [inaudible].
>> Saul Sosnowski: I
saw it, is spectacular.
You mentioned that there was only
one poem that he never touched
because Kafka dictated
that poem to him.
>> Maria Kodama: Yes, yes.
It was very, very funny
because he was always correcting
and correcting, all the
[inaudible] and then I was amazed
because a one poem he never
corrected [inaudible] and he said,
[inaudible] "No I can't, I have
to wait [inaudible] and then,
when Kafka corrects the
poem I'm going to correct,
it's not my poem, it's
Kafka's poem."
>> Saul Sosnowski: That's funny
because at one point he talks about
"Una letrina llamada Kafka"
Although he spells it differently.
Borges used to talk
about the music in poems,
the sense and sounds of poetry.
What kind of music did
you listen with him?
>> Maria Kodama: Well, [inaudible]
because Borges said he was
[inaudible] sordo musical.
>> Saul Sosnowski:
A musical deafness?
>> Maria Kodama: Deafness,
yes musical deafness.
But it's strange because he like
for example [inaudible] and also
for example [inaudible] cannot
here the music [inaudible].
And also he loved for example tangos
de la guardia vieja, because he said
that that kind of tangos are
[inaudible] essence of tangos.
[Inaudible] he doesn't love Gardel,
because he said that Gardel did
with the tango something
sentimental [inaudible].
[Inaudible] and he doesn't like
[inaudible] also the Milonga
because that reminded
him [inaudible]-
>> Saul Sosnowski:
He wrote quite a few.
>> Maria Kodama: Yes, yes of course.
He wrote [inaudible] you know it?
[Inaudible], tangos y
milongas, [inaudible] de tango
of the guardia vieja, [inaudible]
when he was a little boy.
>> Saul Sosnowski: First stage.
How was the Buenos Aires
that you shared with him?
What kind of Buenos Aires did
you work [inaudible] with him?
>> Maria Kodama: [Inaudible]
and usually the [inaudible] very
much [inaudible] because he said
that was the savage's [inaudible],
and then [inaudible]
basement and [inaudible].
>> Saul Sosnowski:
¿El viejo Palermo?
>> Maria Kodama: Yes,
yes, el viejo Palermo.
>> Saul Sosnowski: You
travelled a lot with him.
One of the results is, "The Atlas".
Can you tell us a little
bit about that?
>> Maria Kodama: [Inaudible]
-- very interesting.
>> Saul Sosnowski: Don't
tell the funny stories yet,
I have them for later.
Please wait.
>> Maria Kodama: No, we
enjoyed, we did a lot of travels,
[inaudible] the states
that [inaudible].
In Argentina because [inaudible] we
travelled a lot inside the states.
>> Saul Sosnowski: He also said
Americans are sort of strange people
who say, "hi", to each other.
>> Maria Kodama: [Inaudible] and
that's for him [inaudible] I mean,
it can [inaudible] that's.
>> Saul Sosnowski: Let's go
to one of the fun stories.
I've heard it but I think it's
worth for the people to hear it.
And -- there was a time when you
created names for each other.
You were Rica y Javier
Ottawa [phonetic].
How did those names come about?
>> Maria Kodama: It was [Inaudible]
from [inaudible] and a short story
that was [inaudible] present for me.
[Inaudible] and that's
why I would [inaudible].
>> Saul Sosnowski: So, you came up
with those two names for yourselves?
>> Maria Kodama: Yes,
sometimes [inaudible] different
names [inaudible].
>> Saul Sosnowski: For example?
Those are the two published, tell
us something that is not published.
>> Maria Kodama: No, no, no.
I don't know if I [inaudible].
>> Saul Sosnowski: We will
not repeat it, go ahead.
>> Maria Kodama: [Inaudible] for
example, one of the names was,
once an English journalist
[inaudible] I would call him
Fernando Pérez.
And then sometimes, he send
someone to ask to me [inaudible]
because he was tired, that
means we had to run out,
because he thought he was tired.
And then he said [inaudible],
"no no no,
I called you because [inaudible]"
say that when he saw us coming
into the room, immediately he
thought we were [inaudible] in honor
to that journalist [inaudible].
>> Saul Sosnowski: OK,
not to be repeated.
>> Maria Kodama: Not to be repeated.
>> Saul Sosnowski:
Borges said to you once,
"Su padre la educó para mi"
Your father educated you for me.
And I was thinking of that
in the context of the trip
that you did with a hot air balloon.
>> Maria Kodama: Ah
yes, that's wonderful.
>> Saul Sosnowski: Can you
tell us about that trip?
>> Maria Kodama: Yes, I was
[inaudible] looking something
for a friend of mine who
asked me if I can [inaudible].
Then suddenly I saw the balloons,
[inaudible] immediately will happen,
don't fill these papers, we have to
go [inaudible] trip in the balloon.
At one moment [inaudible]
impossible to make the trip
because [inaudible] married
[inaudible] for the wedding
and then we talked to another
one and [inaudible] and we went.
But we had to go very
very early in the morning,
because of course air balloon
is on fire, and then all night,
he had the the canastita,
[inaudible] the basket is going
to be in [inaudible] or in plástico,
and I said, "Borges, I don't know"
and he said anyway is canasta, no?
Plástico o [inaudible] and when
we arrived, the man said to us,
of course [inaudible]
the balloon and then,
when the balloon descends we have
to una caja [inaudible] and we land.
And one bottle to drink
for the safety trip.
And then it was very funnybecause
the man said [inaudible] he can't
here because [inaudible]
the balloon, [inaudible]
but it's dangerous [inaudible] .
When I was young, I
montar a caballo, montar -
>> Saul Sosnowski:
You still ride a horse
>> Maria Kodama: Yes, ride
the horse, it's not easy --
it's not difficult,
[inaudible] you can hit me
and he said [inaudible] listen, we
[inaudible] no matter what you say,
he's going to [inaudible] you take
care of him and the other person
who is going with us also and
[inaudible] for me, to me.
>> Saul Sosnowski: But not for
Borges, you didn't sign for him?
>> Maria Kodama: No no,
I signed for myself,
the reason [inaudible] OK you
take care of him, I sign for you,
that myself I am going to try
to do the things by myself,
that you are not responsible
if something happens to me,
because you have to take
care of him, not of me.
[Inaudible].
>> Saul Sosnowski: How
long was [inaudible].
>> Maria Kodama: I can't remember,
maybe [inaudible] I can't remember.
>> Saul Sosnowski: That's
a good age [inaudible].
>> Maria Kodama: He enjoyed a lot,
and then we go out with the balloon
and he was so happy, very very happy
[inaudible] amazing, amazing, yes,
he said, "but this sir
is great", [inaudible] is
when he can embrace
[inaudible] Buenos Aires,
it was so beautiful photo of him
between the patas [inaudible]
and ther name was Rosy.
>> Saul Sosnowski: I
hadn't heard that one.
>> Maria Kodama: I'm going
to show you the photo.
>> Saul Sosnowski:
Great, the foundation?
Good. What are the words that
you associate with Borges?
>> Maria Kodama: The
words that I associate --
[inaudible] No matter what.
>> Saul Sosnowski: Everything.
>> Maria Kodama: OK,
[inaudible] freedom, happiness --
Loyalty.
>> Saul Sosnowski:
What was the first one?
>> Maria Kodama: I can't remember,
you don't remember -- [crosstalk].
>> Saul Sosnowski: You said freedom?
Happiness?
And loyalty.
In that order?
>> Maria Kodama: Yes, I suppose
[inaudible], I'm not sure.
>> Saul Sosnowski: Tell us
about the trip to the pyramids.
>> Maria Kodama: The trip to the
pyramids [inaudible] silbó and then
from las piramides salieron unos
[inaudible] y entonces yo le dije,
bueno, mis amigos tienen razón,
esta gente no parece muy confiable,
a uno le falta una oreja
[inaudible] no, no es maravilloso,
la venida aquí esto es maravilloso.
Entonces el [inaudible], el chofer
dijo "bueno, llamadlos [inaudible]",
Borges se sienta, se agarra del
cuello de ellos y ellos empiezan
a correr.
Entonces yo pensaba que adentro de
las pirámides [inaudible] y yo le
decía, "Borges, [inaudible]
Borges, cuidado con la cabeza,
cuidado con la cabeza" Y los
egipcios decían, "Cabiza [phonetic],
cabiza" y reían como locos sujetando
[inaudible] me mira y me dice,
"Maria, no digas cabeza, cabeza,
debe ser una palabra obscena por la
forma en que ellos [inaudible] yo la
repito enseguida, no digas
cabeza" Entonces ellos decían
"Cabiza" entonces yo decía,
quién sabe lo que quiere decir en
árabe y ellos entienden en lugar de
cabeza, "cabiza" [inaudible].
>> Saul Sosnowski: ¿Hay alguien
que sepa árabe y sepa lo que
dice Cabiza?
No, habrá que buscarlo.
>> Melissa: I'm going to
see if I start to check
in the word that she said.
There were homeless people
that came out of the pyramid,
one was missing an
ear and then the --
they carried Borges into the
pyramid, but they were running
and Mrs. Kodama was afraid that
once they entered the pyramids,
and since it was dark he
was going to get hurt.
>> Saul Sosnowski: As he was
being carried along by them.
>> Melissa: Yes, yes.
And she kept repeating, "La
cabeza, la cabeza, you head."
And the men that were
carrying Borges laughed
and repeated, "Cabiza, cabiza."
And so, Borges asked
her not to say cabeza
because he thought it
meant something in Arabic
and they were pronouncing, "Cabiza"
and it was probably and insult.
>> Saul Sosnowski: An obscene word.
>> Melissa: An obscene word, yes.
>> Saul Sosnowski: I've
got a couple more questions
and then we open it to the public.
One of them is, he knew a lot of
languages, some of them self-taught.
Someone asked me, did he
ever learn in braille?
>> Maria Kodama: No [crosstalk].
>> Saul Sosnowski: Why?
>> Maria Kodama: Because
[inaudible].
Because [inaudible] his mother
[inaudible] and then he said,
"é les perezoso", entonces --
>> Saul Sosnowski:
Which is obviously one
of the things he has [inaudible].
You put together a collection
books, like a library.
You and Borges.
The collection of select
books, I wonder how you went
up on selecting the books that
you published in that library.
>> Maria Kodama: The books
that he loved, [inaudible] --
>> Saul Sosnowski: Just
the ones that he loved.
>> Maria Kodama: Yes, just
the books that he loved.
>> Saul Sosnowski: And
the question that --
and with this I'll stop -- maybe.
Can you imagine yourself
doing anything else
in your life had you not met
Borges, what would you have done?
>> Maria Kodama: It's
really interesting
because [inaudible] my
professor [inaudible]
at that moment [inaudible] said
[inaudible] extend el ligamento y no
puedo caminar bien,
pero adoro bailar.
>> Saul Sosnowski: She likes
to dance except there
is a little problem.
>> Maria Kodama: Ligamento,
OK, y luego Borges said,
"en mi familia no ha habido
[inaudible]" pero, me dice,
"Si usted quiere, puede hacerlo."
Ahora yo le voy a explicar
algo, siempre lo explico.
[Inaudible] entonces me dijo,
"Si usted va a la calle [inaudible]
después no puede entra por
[inaudible] se va a sentir muy mal,
en cambio, [inaudible], estudiar,
usted aprende fácilmente, lo que uno
le va a enseñar y eso no tiene fin,
no me dijo que podía.
[Inaudible] lo mismo no?
Entonces me dijo las
cosas por la mitad,
entonces decidí no entrar en
Colón sino seguir estudiando.
>> Saul Sosnowski: Le hiciste caso.
>> Maria Kodama: Sí, no me
di cuenta que le hacía caso,
yo creía que lo hacía yo.
[Laughter] porque no
me dijo toda la verdad.
>> Melissa: So, Borges said to her,
"There's no dancers in my family,
but [crosstalk] yes, fine I'm sorry.
But, he told her, "If you decide
to dance, you'll be able to do it
for a while but after that
you won't be able too.
And on the other hand if you
study and if you want to teach,
that's something you can continue on
doing and so, she decided not to go
to el Teatro Colón,
and continue studying.
>> Saul Sosnowski: And teach.
Which is boundless, we
don't have to retire.
Even if some people want us to.
Right? And.
Before I turn it over,
one more question.
Borges said many times
that he's an agnostic,
but at the same time he talked about
mystical experiences that he had.
What happened there?
How did he blend those
two positions?
>> Maria Kodama: [Inaudible]
agnostic.
>> Saul Sosnowski: Just in case.
Go ahead.
>> Maria Kodama: Just in case?
OK, but he said that he has
these mystic experiences
when he wrote at night [inaudible].
One was in el Barrio Sur, en
un atardecer, en un anochecer,
él sintió que estaba
fuera del tiempo,
entonces esto lo impresionó mucho y
esa es la experiencia que sintió así
que era no normal o lógico.
En fin, en la obra de él hay
muchísimas citas a la Biblia,
pero eso era por el lado
de su abuela inglesa,
él me decía que en esa época para
los católicos estaba prohibido leer
la Biblia por temer a
la mala interpretación -
>> Saul Sosnowski: Hacían bien.
>> Maria Kodama: En cambio los
protestantes hasta el día de hoy
tienen las Biblias [inaudible] y su
abuela sabía [inaudible] entonces
eso le quedó muy fuertemente unido
a su parte digamos intelecutal,
y la prueba es que a lo largo de
su obra hay muchísimas [inaudible]
Biblia, Jesucristo, no desde el
punto de vista de la creencia total
pero si --
>> Saul Sosnowski: Búsqueda
de coherencia [inaudible].
>> Melissa: One of those mystic
experience was during a walk
at night in Barrio Sur.
He felt that he was out of
time and that impressed him,
he felt something that
wasn't normal, wasn't logical
as if it were another dimension.
In his work there are a lot
of references from the Bible
and this comes from his
English grandmother.
She knew parts of the
Bible by memory
and this influenced his intellectual
life, not from a point of view
of him believing in religion.
>> Saul Sosnowski: Did he
always think [inaudible] is his
best [inaudible]?
>> Maria Kodama: No, he
changed his [inaudible] --
>> Saul Sosnowski: Do you have
any other one besides [inaudible]
that he considered his
best or his favorite?
>> Maria Kodama: No, I can't
remember the name [inaudible]
but sometimes he said
that [inaudible] Le gustaba mucho y
también el que escribió a su abuelo
[inaudible] a su abuelo que
[inaudible] cinco años y él lo cuidó
en su delirio y muere
en una batalla,
entonces es tristísimo porque él
dice que él tenía cinco años cuando
su abuelo murió y le decían que se
había ido d eviaje y entonces él
caminaba por la casa tratando
de encontrar a su abuelo,
era una cosa muy triste, sí.
>> Melissa: So, besides [inaudible],
another poem that he mentioned a
lot was, "El otro Tigre" and one
that he wrote for his
grandfather who died in battle,
Borges was five years old when
his grandfather passed away.
And he was told that
he have gone on a trip.
So Borges, as a child used to look
for his grandfather not
knowing that he had passed.
>> Saul Sosnowski: OK.
Open to the public, questions.
Somebody will bring you a mic.
>> Gracias, pregunto en castellano
y después traduzco si quieren.
>> Saul Sosnowski: Sí.
>> Me interesa mucho lo que dijo
acerca de la libertad y la lealtad
como dos de las palabras
que [inaudible] en Borges,
porque creo que [inaudible] a cierta
obediencia incondicional a cierta
proximidad la constante y
la libertad por otra parte,
una suerte de partida
o de separación.
Yo no creo que las dos sean
contradictorias en absoluto,
y se pueden conjugar bien,
y creo que [inaudible] me interesa
saber qué era la lealtad para
ustedes, y la libertad
y cómo se combinaban.
And in English, basically I think
that traditionally freedom
implies a certain kind
of unconditional proximity and
loyalty and freedom are kind
of distance or departure [phonetic]
how did you and Borges minded
to in order to achieve that
happiness that you described?
What was loyalty for you
and what was freedom for you
and why were they not contradictory.
>> Maria Kodama: Bueno, yo creo que
no son contrditorios la libertad y
la lealtad, ¿cierto?
Porque la libertad [inaudible] y la
lealtad es la [inaudible] me gute o
no me guste, OK [inaudubke] y la
lealtad es digamos la [inaudible] a
través de la cual nosotros,
digamos, estamos interiormente,
cómo puedo decir, no privados pero
sí tenemos que tener la conciencia
de que no podemos digamos
[inaudible],
es decir tenemos que ser
fieles a nuestras ideas,
a nuestros ideales de vida.
Yo creo que esos son los términos
que no se contradicen sino que
[inaudible] a mi forma
de pensar se unen,
se completan, no sé si te contesté.
Gracias.
>> Melissa: [Inaudible] and
freedom contradict each other,
and were the liberty is not
freedom, Rather is not libertinaje?
>> Saul Sosnowski: OK,
we have translators here,
how do you say libertinaje?
[Inaudible] it's not -- it doesn't
exist in the Spanglish language,
we don't practice it so, let's
proceed [inaudible] right.
It was better the other way.
>> Melissa: With respect to the
loyalty, that conscience of not --
not going against someone
else's ideals and she feels
that they complement each other
rather than contradicting.
>> Saul Sosnowski: Another question?
Over there.
>> Gracias.
Voy la hago en castellano
la pregunta,
con respecto a esa experiencia
de Borges, de modernidad,
de esa experiencia espiritual que
mencionaste que había ocurrido en el
sur, y luego inmediatamente se me
ocurrió asociarlo [inaudible] no sé
si es que exista alguna conexión.
>> Maria Kodama: Bueno
posiblemente sí exista ¿no?
Posiblemente esa experiencia
[inaudible] ese cuento, y no sé,
no puedo decirlo con seguridad,
pero no es [inaudible] ya que
esa experiencia es realmente una
experiencia mística, ¿no?
De alguna manera puede llegar a
ver así todas las cosas en punto.
Y es muy divertido porque él me
contaba que ese cuento se le reveló
[inaudible] caleidoscopio,
estaba jugando con un
caleidoscopio [inaudible].
>> A todos nos pasa lo mismo.
[Laughter]
>> Saul Sosnowski: Yeah,
[inaudible] go for it.
¿Me permites un tantito esto?
>> Melissa: It's possible
that that mystical experience
of Borges could have
shaped [inaudible],
but she doesn't know for sure.
Because they are both,
could be both,
[inaudible] mystic experiences,
but that story came to Borges,
the short story [inaudible] while
playing with the kaleidoscope.
>> Saul Sosnowski: You
didn't mention that one time
where he was interviewed
by a Spanish journalist
who got very upset with him because
Borges mentions the exact location
of where the Aleph is and
someone had told the journalist
that he had made it up and
got very angry and left him
and said, "vale, vale, vale".
We have a question over there.
>> [Inaudible] en español.
Cómo era Borges en día a día
considerando la cambiante y
constante actividad o la
política Argentina, era pasional,
lo tomaba a veces con humor,
se enganchaba terriblemente,
digamos se preocupaba
mucho, o digamos,
los cambios políticos en Argentina
que fueron muchísimos toda su vida,
lo preocupaba mucho y de alguna
manera lo quería expresar en los
libros, ¿no?
I can translate it
[inaudible] the life of Borges,
in relation with Argentinian
political situation [inaudible]
probably in all his life
changed a lot, that continuous
to change every day, but I want to
ask how was his humor with that,
how was his relation with that,
if he was very anxious with that,
or not, or if he was very
passionned [inaudible] politics
of Argentina, how he feel?
>> Maria Kodama: Mira, I think
that [inaudible] the different
political situations [inaudible]
and he was always very clear
and [inaudible] someone
who said [inaudible] for him
of course because [inaudible]
in his mind, but, he
was very I think,
very clear [inaudible] dictatorship
and that's why he was free
and a free person cannot
undertand that kind
of [inaudible] time
[inaudible] about that, yes.
>> Saul Sosnowski:
One final question.
>> Yo tenía un comentario
muy rápido que es que
"cabiza" quiere decir
"lío" en árabe.
>> Maria Kodama: Thank
you, thank you.
>> Saul Sosnowski: That sort
of makes sense considering
that they were carrying
him on his arms,
that makes a lot of
sense, thank you.
>> [Inaudible] de corazón
[inaudible] cuán quisquilloso era
Borges para la comida,
qué cosas él no comía,
qué cosas si le gustaba bastante,
que no [inaudible] que siempre
quería comer o [inaudible].
So, in English, keeping with the
[inaudible] how picky was Borges
in regards of food,
what would he not touch,
what would he really
like to eat, or drink.
>> Saul Sosnowski: That is
definitely a Cuban question.
[Inaudible].
>> Maria Kodama: He loved arroz
con manteca y queso, and cheese.
[inaudible] always
[inaudible] whose name was Maxim
that was [inaudible] near Florida,
in Buenso Aires, and then we went
to [inaudible] invited us to a
restaurant in [inaudible], he said,
OK, the man began drink this
wine, and Borges drink, he said,
"I don't drink wine" then the man
began to explain the food, and the -
and then, the chef, the restaurant
[inaudible] was [inaudible] Borges
said, "OK, I want to eat
arroz con manteca y queso",
then the man said --
Borges, we are in Maxims --
and he said - this is
a sucursal of Maxim
in Buenos Aires [inaudible] is the
best restaurant de [inaudible] OK,
I want to know how is the taste
of my favourite dish
arroz con manteca y queso
in the best restaurant in the world.
>> Saul Sosnowski: On that
note, we thank Maria Kodama
for sharing these memories with us
and to be continuing
until another time.
Thank you all for being here.
[ Applauses ]
>> This has been a presentation
by the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov